is a rebounder just as good as the vibration plate for lymphatics.
Or you just have to do it for longer.
For lymphatics.
So the vibration plate, the benefit of the vibration plate is you get the muscle
fasciculation just by standing on the plate.
You're not doing any exercise.
Now you can exercise on a vine plate.
And then you're getting the benefit of still the muscle fasciculation and the contraction of muscles
depending on what exercise you're doing.
So by far the vine plate is more efficient.
What's better to move lymph?
That's a difficult question to answer.
I'd still probably say the vine plate.
Probably just because it's more efficient.
So in the same amount of time that you're on the rebounder versus on the vine plate
you're going to probably get a lot more muscle contraction on the vine plate.